hundreds March in the streets of niger's
capital Naomi a show of support for a
military coup that has shaken many West
African countries and their
International backers because of the
potential security implications for the
entire region
the French army must get out of Nigeria
there's no reason for them to be in
Niger they are the terrorists
defense ministers from ecowas met for a
second day in the Nigerian Capital Abuja
to discuss how to resolve the crisis the
regional economic and security
organization says military intervention
in Nigeria could be a last resort
the leader of niger's coup is refusing
to back down but says he hopes for a
peaceful solution
we've always been humble enough to
listen to all the parties concerned and
open to dialogue so that everyone's
emotions have subsided we can work
together to create the conditions for a
peaceful transition leading in a
relatively short and reasonable time to
general elections but above all to a
better approach in our fight against
terrorism and other economic and social
ills
Senegal says it would participate in an
ecowas military operation if the
regional block is forced to intervene
why should our soldiers go there they
are going for two reasons the first is
because we are in a community
organization that has decided that and
that is called ecowas Senegal is an
international signatory we can't be a
member of ecowas without subscribing to
the decisions taken by it
France the former colonial power to
which coup supporters have directed much
of their anger said it had completed an
evacuation of over a thousand people
almost 600 of them French
this is the seventh coup in West Africa
in recent years
since the military leadership in Mali
and Burkina Faso forced French and U.N
troops to leave Niger was seen as one of
the last bastions of an international
effort to defeat armed groups like Isis
and Al-Qaeda France and the U.S have
bases in Niger
Russia has condemned the coup that some
demonstrators have carried Russian Flags
West African countries and their Western
backers fear the Russian mercenary group
Wagner already helping Mali and Burkina
Faso fight armed groups May step into a
security vacuum and offer Niger Health
also
according to Echo as Terror attacks are
on the rise and there are fears that
armed groups responsible could take
advantage of a further deterioration in
the security situation
[Music]
the new head of ecowas Nigeria's
president bolatinubu had raised concerns
about the regional Block's ability to
prevent more coups and fight armed
groups and that was before the military
Takeover in Niger how ecowas responds in
the coming days while avoiding a violent
escalation is one of the biggest
challenges this region has faced in
decades John Stratford Al Jazeera the
car